why did Grisha tell Zeke to stop Aaron
but then still go on to give Aaron the
founding Titan if he really wanted to
stop the rambling he could have just not
given Aaron the power in the first place
which would have prevented his son from
ever having the ability to release the
wall Titans however one thing you need
to remember is that when Grisha told
Zeke to stop Aaron he had no idea that
back home Carl had just been eaten by a
Titan when he did eventually find out
what happened he knew it was the
Warriors who were responsible and so he
gave the founder to Aaron so that he
could get revenge in fact in chapter 71
he literally said the words Aaron you
must avenge your mother